claiming back territory isn't the same
as it being secure the soldiers moved
into european cautiously despite in the
president's words they'd liberated the
town is irpin liberated is it free
have you reclaimed
only so so they tell us this commuter
town near the capital has been the focus
of intense russian attacks for more than
a month
none of these soldiers were taking
anything for granted despite the first
major russian concession since the start
of the invasion
so the area is clearly still not secure
and they're going in to try and find out
just how much further the russian troops
have been pushed back
the sounds of war rumbled on whilst the
peace talks continued under ukrainian
martial law we're not allowed to show
this location
but any scaling back of russian military
operations around the capital come at a
tremendous cost with terrible
destruction done to small towns like
european which has been bombarded for
weeks
those still holding the lines around the
capital are very skeptical about any
cessation of hostilities
how many times have we heard about a
ceasefire the first fighter says it's
always just our side which sticks to it
then we get attacked and we have to
reply
the second man says the russians haven't
stuck to any agreement so far
the first time we set up a humanitarian
corridor in urpin he tells us they just
attacked the civilian convoy
there are still civilians being taken
out of the embattled town after more
than four weeks of being trapped there
many of them are elderly and not in very
good health those too scared to leave or
with nowhere to go
thank you all of you she says to the
emergency crews
she's gently guided to a rest area
she can hardly carry the few belongings
she's managed to take out with her
this has been a terrible ordeal for them
all she's still clearly shocked barely
able to speak
they've been living with almost constant
attacks all this time do you have any
place to go anyone who can help you
she's asked
i don't have anyone she tells the
emergency worker i don't have anyone at
all
her husband and her have been sheltering
in their basement for a month
she gulps her tea with sheer relief it's
her first hot drink for weeks
[Music]
they've had no electricity gas or water
and drank from their well with their
food stocks running out
any scaling down in the fighting comes
twinned with so much heartache and
suffering too
she tells us she's really worried she
won't ever see her daughter and
granddaughter again
the realization is really tough for her
some said they've been held captive by
the russian troops herded into homes and
used as shields to prevent ukrainian
attacks
when they came into our house they took
people from all around and put us all in
one basement galena tells us there were
about 40 of us and then around the house
they put one tank on one side and
another tank on the other side and a
third in the yard
they've lost so much amid so much trauma
our opinion was so beautiful allah says
it's all completely destroyed now
there's plenty of destruction elsewhere
too in several villages surrounding the
capital this one east of the country's
main city was apparently retaken two
days ago after much fighting and a lot
of shelling
the military hardware now in ukrainian
hands is paraded as evidence of how the
russians have been beaten back the
offers by them to radically reduce some
of their military activity will be
viewed by the ukrainian troops as an
offer rung out of them due to these
successes on the battlefields around the
capital alex crawford sky news on the
outskirts of kiev